ihr dürft zieles gründung rote fragen
die wurden dem harmlos die roten sind
gemein wer möchte anfangen ich war mit
grüner okay also diesen bauch pinseln
global akku laut vorlesen
aber selbstverständlich ist so gedacht
dass diese ominöse frau von der mittels
mal erzählt dass man das getackert du
hast die frau getackert auch nicht das
maul im video zu dicke eier ist die
macht mit euch
das ist eine frage die ich schwer
beantworten kann weil ich überhaupt
nicht glaubt dass aus star wars richtig
und ich war nicht star wars fan weiß
nicht was in eurem video ist ich habe
nein ich habe gefragt sagt wer ist
dieser typ netzwerk das motto und so
weiter und schwert und so aber ich
gehöre zu einer anderen generation ich
war es gab ihr kampfstern galactica
versucht das weiß ja sehr fest und gab
es auch sterne genau mit lohengrin und
ich war noch so knapp kampfstern
galactica
ich war aber viel mehr raumschiff
enterprise und krieg der sterne so das
war für mich das haben die babys geguckt
die elfjährigen jahrgang 1933 die
kriegsgeneration ein neuer bat doch auch
stalingrad bald lieber erst kam
enterprise dann kam star wars und dann
kam kampfstern galactica nähe ist es so
ja natürlich haben sie gelogen als ich
war sie kriege ich weiß es einfach mich
ich war kalt verfickte krieg der sterne
fan
mit diesem mix 2 2 und dj bobo und r2 d2
sorry hab ich was verpasst was mich
hätte prägen können okay gut nächste
frage wissen was schief gelaufen ist
nämlich rot natürlich sonst bin ich ein
feigling
naja wie da drüben
einfach so in der mitte du musst als
oberteil damals unter mayrhuber der frau
so die polizei was das für niveau dazu
muss ich eine kleine anekdote erzählen
wir haben eine modischen gemachten
listening session um einfach unser album
leuten vorzustellen
da waren rund dabei ich bin nicht gegen
zwischen 50 und 100 man wandern alle
haben es probe gehört das album wir
haben ungefähr elf oder zwölf songs von
16vor gespielt und haben die leute
anonym weil wir wirklich ehrliche
antworten haben wollten
fragebögen ausfüllen lassen und unter
anderem war die frage was ist die
potenziell beste single und 90 prozent
von allen leuten meinen hintern polizei
und wir sind selber vom glauben
abgefallen die nummer wollten wir erst
gar nicht aufs album nehmen weil sie so
eine total du regel nummer ist und
dadurch mehr dur akkorde also
karnevalsschlager mäßig halten wobei hey
was geht ab sind ja auch eher mulack
wurde und der trend geht glaube ich auf
mallorca in den letzten jahren auch er
so in diese moll akkord ist kein geld
mehr da und ich meine dicke eier haben
wir vorhin erklärt also das niveau ist
ganz hoch eigentlich und hinter polizei
sollte erst wirklich gar nicht aufs
album drauf kommen es waren am anfang
war es noch viel grottenschlechter
grottig es war wirklich so es war ein
karibischer weitere täter
dann habe mir gedacht komm dann machen
wir wenigstens ein elektro beat runter
und dann läuft das ding froböse ihr
rotes böse jetzt
ja ich habe jetzt genug
jetzt habe ich das kaputt gemacht jetzt
habe ich es kaputt gemacht seid ihr auf
krawall gebürstet oder wird sonst keiner
auf euch aufmerksam
das ist eine suggestivfrage kann ganz
weil sie möchte uns suggerieren wir
wollten auf uns aufmerksam machen
dadurch dass wir auf krawall gebürstet
seien antwort a wir wollen nicht auf uns
aufmerksam machen schon gar nicht
dadurch dass sie auf krawall gebürstet
sind sondern ich glaube du hast das so
verstanden und aufmerksam machen auf
euch weil hier auch nicht ins interview
gekommen
wir haben genug aufmerksamkeit also ich
glaube die hier ins interview zu kommen
hat natürlich erstmal sinn und zweck
auch sich zu verbreiten aber und
vielleicht unterschätzt du deine
durchaus sympathische ausstrahlung auch
die dazu treten
ich wurde ja mal zu erwähnen weil du das
sage ich ganz ehrlich jetzt jemand bis
einer der wenigen die sich in einem
interview mit ihrem gesprächspartner
auseinandersetzen und deswegen ist es
mir eine freude zu dir zu kommen ganz
abgesehen davon dass das natürlich auch
die verbreitung unseres mediums zur
folge hat aber es ist nicht darauf
angelegt dass wir so wie andere
namenhafte künstler erst den skandal
erzeugen und dann den inhalt hinterher
wenn es jetzt wenn man videos in einen
goldenen rahmen spannen könnte würde ich
diese antwort war auch noch in 20 jahren
wenn sich rausstellt was für gangster
ich habe eine kollegin die sagt er sie
sagte immer ahmed sind sie alle auch die
arschlöcher in köln hat die polizei den
computer eines 48-jährigen
fernsehjournalisten kompliziert auf die
meldung war
millionen von na ja hätte gelangen
ausflug in die musikwelt läuft wohl
nicht
dollar auf deutschlands achso ausflug in
die musikwelt läuft wohl nicht mehr so
dolle auf deutschlands bühnen oder serra
ich habe jetzt im schnitt 3000 zuschauer
am abend der und tour planen das ist
jetzt seit einem jahr ausverkauft
woher diese 3400 thale in karlsruhe in
der schwarzwaldhalle in oldenburg weser
ems halle in berlin im tempodrom
und das ohne einen einzigen auftritt im
fernsehen zu haben oder mich von mario
barth und konsorten penetrieren lassen
zu müssen
es läuft eigentlich ganz dolle würde ich
sagen und dass ich musik mache hat gar
nichts damit zu tun dass ich irgendwo
ein frust entwickelt habe und meine mir
jetzt eine ersatzbefriedigung holen zu
müssen sondern ich hab da bock drauf und
ich leiste mir das unabhängig davon ob
irgendein penner meint meinem
psychoanalytiker spielen zu müssen
okay gut wunderbar sehr schön machen wir
noch eine frage eine grüne und dann aber
auf und lassen das ewige rätsel
damit du noch was macht damit auch die
letzte grüne frage war die wenn man ihn
wenn er jetzt nicht widerstehen
willst du wirklich schwul der erste
single kommt super an danke für euer
album in den top ten
die haben wir uns überlegt ja erstmal
danke für das kompliment oder ist das
jetzt so eine hypothese eure erste
kompakte hat oder weiß ich nicht wenn du
das sagst
die resonanz war mir gegenüber immer
positiv verrückte teuer album in den top
ten das ist schwer zu sagen weil auch
wenn jetzt in der gleichen woche
irgendwie heino mit einem neuen single
ding daherkommt dann ist es schwer weil
das wird er nicht an den verkaufszahlen
die man sonst hat gemessen sondern an
den gesamt verkaufszahlen und wenn
andere künstler zu der zeit natürlich
mehr verkaufen
ist es schwieriger aber ich würde mal
sagen ja ist schaltet in den top ten auf
jeden fall hoffentlich kaufen
wir drücken ja danke ok ich danke euch
jemals